dans soir 3 politique francis letellier
reçoit françois bayrou il y a de plus en
plus de concurrents sauf entre le
président du modem va réagir ce soir à
la décision de jean-louis borloo de
quitter l'ump
quelles sont les conséquences pour 2012
françois bayrou bonsoir bonsoir jean
louis borloo a donc avancé il ya
quelques jours qu'il allait quitter
l'ump c'est un premier pas pour une
candidature éventuelle en 2012 vous
n'avez pas encore réagi alors qu'en
penser je vous attendais ce alors qu'en
pensez vous tout à l'heure je prenais
l'avion à l'aéroport de biarritz et un
policier était là il est venu me voir il
m'a dit monsieur bayrou côté faut que je
vous dise je peux vous parler en liberté
parce que je vais prendre ma retraite
mais tous les jours on nous manipule et
on nous dit jamais la vérité
alors on va sur cette opération dire la
vérité
est ce que c'est une opération
d'indépendance du centre comme on dit
non c'est une opération qui vise à
ramener le centre dans la majorité vers
nicolas sarkozy vers nicolas sark vide
dans la majorité c'est une opération qui
vise à faire croire que le centre ne
peut exister que d'un seul côté de
l'échiquier à droite à droite et cette
opération est une opération qui manque
de crédibilité
pourquoi elles manquent de crédibilité
aux il suffit de regarder le pedigree de
ceux qui la propose
jean-louis borloo a été ministre sans
interruption tout au long des cinq
années de jacques chirac
et puis il a été ministre sans
interruption numéro deux du gouvernement
tout au long des quatre années qui
viennent de s'écouler sous la
magistrature de nicolas sarkozy alors
jamais en avant jamais il n'a trouvé une
réserve à exprimer donc il n'est pas
crédible pour près de 12 et donc venir
dire aujourd'hui qu'il faut battre
nicolas sarkozy kiss
qu'il faut battre nicolas sarkozy selon
moi ça manque de crédibilité et c'est
quelque chose de l'iran comme moi un
sondage qui est paru aujourd'hui dans le
journal du dimanche réalisé par l'ifop
qui montre que jean louis borloo est au
même niveau vous à peu près pour
représenter le centre ça veut dire quand
même que c'est un concurrent sérieux
pour vais bien je ne commente que très
peu les sondages mais si vous citez ce
sondage alors il faut que vous alliez au
bout la question lorsqu'elle est posée
aux électeurs du centre elle dit deux
fois plus d'intentions de vote pour
françois bayrou que pour cent de
l'elysée qui veulent non pas du tout le
quand vous interrogez les électeurs
socialistes sur la primaire socialiste
toujours dans le sondage
on donne la question des réponses des
électeurs et donc je dis que peut il y a
là une absence de crédibilité et une
absence d'un dépend alors ça pose une
question est ce que ça va accélérer
votre calendrier est ce que vous allez
vous déclarer pour 2012 plutôt prévu est
ce que vous serez candidat en 2012
en tout cas je mènerai ce combat je le
mènerai et je défendrai cette
proposition d'un centre qui n'est en
effet pas verrouillées a pris en otage à
l'intérieur d'une alliance quelle
qu'elle soit et je ne participerai à
aucune combinaison aucune primaire a
aucun à aucune combinaison qui viserait
à enlever à cette famille politique son
indépendance et sa capacité de proposer
cela veut dire un mot important une
alternance mais vous sa calebasse ameuté
à dire écoutez nous allons dans la
france où nous sommes regardés
nous avons trois guerres sur les bras on
va y revenir si vous l'aimez les images
une âme entraînant lèvres dire laissez
moi allez je vous promets au bout de
cette phrase parce qu'on peut pas
l'écarter de cette manière nous avons
trois guerres sur les bras
cette semaine les chiffres qui ont été
publiés du commerce extérieur de la
france sont des chiffres plus graves
qu'ils n'ont jamais été dans notre
histoire et le la substance de la france
où la sève de la france s'échappe comme
une hémorragie
on va on mais nous avons une
démoralisation du pays comme il y en a
jamais eu
ceux ci ne se réglera pas par des
combinaisons alors ce signe à se réglera
pas entendu par des manoeuvres ya un
troisième mandant toulois kif il faut
aller au bout de cette de cette
reconstruction du pays sur des bases
nouvelles
oui il y un troisième homme qui frappent
à la porte c'est dominique de villepin
l'ancien premier ministre doit présenter
son programme jeudi prochain il a livré
son sentiment sur la candidature de jean
louis borloo
il ya un certain nombre de critiques
fortes qui sont aujourd'hui émises par
jean louis borloo
il connaît bien nicolas sarkozy ils ont
travaillé ensemble pendant les quatre
dernières années ne dessine pas un
dealer du jour au lendemain ces quatre
années elles ont marqué des liens
profonds entre les deux hommes elles ont
marqué l accord sur une politique qui a
été menée aujourd'hui aujourd'hui borloo
souhaite reprendre ses distances
seul l'avenir nous dira la portée du
geste qu'il soit accompli la même
critique et dylan ce que vous vous
pourriez travailler avec 2002 vite un
film et une je peux travailler avec
quiconque a une volonté de changement
profond de notre pays de ses
institutions de la manière dont ce pays
portent ce qu'il doit aux français
l'éducation par exemple la santé ou la
sécurité
c'est cela en tout cas je peux
travailler avec eux en guerre un besoin
il ya beaucoup de gens qui nous écoutent
dans 700 politiques il ya beaucoup de
gens qui nous écoutent ils ont envie de
rapprochement mais ces rapprochements ne
pourront se faire que si on écarte les
ambiguïtés et les hypocrisies et bien il
ya là-dessous ça amène tout à fait ce
dont on va parler maintenant c'est la
bataille au centre quand même qui est
engagée et jérôme dorville chef du
service politique de france 3 nous
rejoint pour pour nous le dira jérôme
apparemment il y a quand même bon soir
de la concurrence du côté du centre
oui le centre dans le paysage politique
c'est un peu comme la voie du milieu sur
l'autoroute vous savez la plus encombrée
celle où l'on est sûr de se faire
doubler sur sa droite comme sur sa
gauche
et pourtant en effet regarder l'horizon
une fois encore en direction des 10 et
les candidats s'engouffrent dans cette
file surchargé dernière en date on en a
parlé jean louis borloo parti sur les
chapeaux de roue
ils s'imaginent au volant d'une idf
relooker une sorte d'hybride un peu
radical socialiste un peu écolo
centriste une machine bien carrossées
qui pourraient distancer le diesel
villepin qui n'arrive pas à prendre de
la vitesse qui pourrait freiner le
candidat écolo surtout s'il s'appelle
hulot qui pourrait aussi gêner la
trajectoire du champion socialiste
surtout s'il a le visage de dsk mais
celui qui aura peut-être le plus de mal
à tenir sa moyenne c'est vous françois
bayrou s'il ne change pas de direction
s'il reste pied au plancher jean louis
borloo peut espérer en effet voir se
dégager la voie du sang tu mets question
françois bayrou est ce que cette voie du
centre est encore la plus appropriée la
plus efficace pour franchir le portail
de l'elysée au moment où on le voit la
france et est tenaillé tiraillé par des
tentation populiste parfois droitière
vous présenter la chose comme s'il
s'agissait de compétition et simplement
de trouver un poste
et excusez moi de vous le dire c'est pas
de ça qu'il s'agit
vous faites de la politique vous suivez
la politique depuis un certain temps moi
j'y participe depuis longtemps je puis
vous assurer que je n'ai jamais trouvé
le pays dans l'état où il se trouve et
continuer avec la majorité que nous
avons aujourd'hui c'est être assuré que
les mêmes causes produiront leurs effets
des nous à comprendre le centre city à
part vous le centre c'est tous ceux en
france qui disent il faut une alternance
et en même temps cette alternance on ne
peut pas là confié mais à 100% au ps qui
par exemple est bien tous les tous les
élus qui appartiennent au mouvement que
je dirige tous ses militants et
sympathisants tous ceux qui en 2007
manifesté leur volonté et tout ce qui
ailleurs dans les 12 mois qui viennent
vont se dire mais au fond dans cette
affaire là il faut écarter tout ce qui
change d'avis au fur et à mesure que les
sondages évoluent ils sont avec nicolas
sarkozy quand il est trés ou sociaux
contre nicolas sarkozy il répondu à ma
question est est ce que le climat
vraiment se prêtent là à l'affirmation
d'un centre fort alors que ce qu'on
entend plus tôt c'est une petite musique
droitière sinon parfois extrémistes
rapidement eh bien c'est exactement le
contraire que je pense je pense qu on ne
reconstruira le pays que si on est
capable d'équilibrer de modération
j'allais dire de sagesse et que si on
pousse le pays dans le sens des extrêmes
il ya beaucoup d' extrême disponible à
l'heure actuelle on le déchirera et on
l'empêchera de relever les défis qui
sont les siens alors il est mortel
annonce un peu il est mortel non mais si
on pose des questions graves ou when
they réponse il est mortel de pousser un
pays comme celui-là devant les défis où
nous sommes vers la division c'est
mortel et c'est pourquoi ce qu'ils ont
comme visée l'unité du pays
ce qu'ils disent mais on peut travailler
avec des gens de bonne foi
même s'ils n'ont pas la même carte
politique dans la poche ceux là sont les
seuls qui propose une réponse viable
alors ya un autre candidat qui pourrait
se déclarer jérôme vous en ai parlé tout
à l'heure c'est nicolas hulot et ça
c'est l'un des moments forts de la
semaine à venir
oui tout à fait mercredi nicolas hulot
effectivement atterri dans le 9-3 c'est
à dire en seine saint denis pour
annoncer sa candidature présidentielle
l'explorateur cathodique a choisi la
ville de sevran une commune qui cumule
on le sait toutes les difficultés et les
souffrances de certaines banlieues
une façon pour lui de dépasser son image
d' écolo bobo loi des réalités sociales
du pays françois bayrou
si vous aviez à choisir entre les majors
y à nicolas hulot à calais selon vous le
crédit écoutez je je je livre
suffisamment de combat sans avoir besoin
de me fait ch et deux sur quoi avec des
gens qui sont sur une autre trajectoire
que la mienne je pense que nicolas hulot
est quelqu'un de sincère au fond de moi
même je pense que nous pourrions un jour
avoir à travailler ensemble en même
temps est-ce qu'il va lever devoir
déjouer les pièges
oui est ce qu'il va pouvoir déjouer les
pièges qui vont lui être tendu je ne
sais pas vous avez des comparaisons ça
va faire plaisir aux écologistes à ce
que vous venez de dire ben j'imagine que
vous savez j'ai des contacts avec
beaucoup d'écologistes
j'ai eu des contacts avec eva joly
assidus pourquoi pourquoi parce que dans
un pays comme le nôtre il faut que les
responsables politiques sérieux puisse
parler
ouais et un jour travailler on va parler
d'autres responsables politiques on va
parler que de 2 millions si vous n'y
aura pas il n'y aura pas de
reconstruction du pays dirigé par une
seule un seul parti une seule
sensibilité
c'est ça notre différence vous disiez
tout à l'heure qu'est-ce que centre veut
dire centre veut dire que on peut
travailler écouter respecter estimé des
gens même s'ils sont pas dans votre
partie à condition que leur conviction
soit en béton et qu'on puisse parler
d'autre chose parce que leurs fonds sur
eux il faut qu'on parle aussi de ce qui
se passe dans le monde vous savez que la
france avait compris ce que je dis bien
sûr que la france est engagée en côte
d'ivoire en libye notamment et en
afghanistan et ça pousse question vous
allez l'entendre à laurent fabius
la france sait très bien qu'elle
intervienne mais on ne peut pas
intervenir partout
nous avons près de 2000 hommes au liban
nous avons près de 2000 hommes en côte
d'ivoire nous avons quatre mille hommes
en afghanistan
nous avons des troupes au kosovo nous
avons maintenant des troupes en libye
il faut choisir nos interventions
intervention de
france lorsqu'elle est justifiée oui
interventionnisme allant jusqu'à
l'enlisement non retravailleront vous
pensé la même chose que laurent fabius
il faut faire des choix stratégiques
politiques
je pense pas exactement la même chose je
vais essayer de le dire avec mes mots
nous avons trois guerres sur les bras et
c'est beaucoup pour un pays comme le
nôtre et nous avons trois guerres sur
les bras en particulier parce que nous
n'avons pas su construire la seule le
seul recours que des pays démocratiques
devrait avoir dans cette affaire et pour
nous ça s'appelle europe c'est parce que
l'europe est absente lointaines sans
volonté qu'on n'a pas su insuffler cette
vision là que nous nous trouvons nous
france avec trois interventions sur les
bras et ça dépasse enfin ça n'est pas
comme on dit en écologie ça n'est pas
soutenable
ce n'est pas durable en 2000 et voudra
revoir la 10 place des politiques
économiques en france
je crois que pour 2012 faudra revoir
profondément la manière dont la france
conçoit son avenir son rôle dans
l'europe et dans le monde
il est légitime qu'elles aient un rôle
c'est un pays dont la vision fait partie
de l'identité et en même temps
naturellement elle peut pas conduire
tout seul ce type d'opération ce qui
veut dire que ce en europe
c'est notre influence qui s'affaiblit
merci beaucoup france